We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p.
This voicemail color is asking about whether
I'm going to be campaigning for any, uh, 2020
Democratic candidates.
Let's listen to the voicemail and there's
actually a bigger discussion here that I've
been wanting to have with you.
Take a listen.
Hey David, this is your, this is David's from
California.
I just wanted to know, are you going to get
on any campaign trail?
Are you going to back any candidate?
You seem to have a lot of information, good
information, and you seem to explain yourself
well.
I think maybe you could be an asset.
So I hope that you find a candidate you believe
in and then explain to us why you believe
in it.
Um, I'd like to hear your opinion.
I mean there's some good ones after there.
I think there's some good ones that aren't
going to make the cut based on their age experience
or just not the right time.
Okie doke.
Bye.
Yeah.
So listen, I've made clear, I'm going to eventually
tell you who I support in the 2020 democratic,
um, uh, a primary eye.
It's an open question.
I mean, I'm not going to be out on the campaign
trail.
Let me put it that way.
I'm doing my show and I want to, even if it's
known who I'm supporting, I want to be doing
credible analysis of, uh, of the campaign
and of the race.
So I don't see myself campaigning for anybody.
Um, although circumstances could change who,
who knows?
Uh, I don't know whether it makes sense for
me to particularly early on say who I'm going
to be supporting and I genuinely don't know
who that is at this point in time.
I mean, I've made clear, I like Bernie.
I supported him in 2016 I like Elizabeth Warren.
Andrew Yang has some interesting ideas, although
I think within a week, uh, within 10 days
we may know whether or not he's going to have
any chance whatsoever at this thing because
if he doesn't get to like three or 4% in the
polling after next week's presidential debate,
I think he's basically done.
And in fact, he won't be allowed in the next
set of debates unless he gets to, I think
it's three or 4% in the national polls.
I don't know what the audience wants me to
do on this.
I, I again, I'm going to tell you ultimately
who I'm voting for in the primary and there
is a almost total certainty that in the general
election I will vote for the Democratic nominee.
I'm not going to vote for Trump.
It's conceivable that something could happen.
Where in Massachusetts where, uh, it's effectively
a guarantee that the Democrat will win.
Would I support a third party candidate?
Maybe, and I'll be totally transparent with
you, but I don't know that there is much to
be gained from me at this point.
You know, I see channels where people are,
they're jumping on the Yang gang or they're
Bernie or busters or they're saying I'm with
Liz or they're saying a Tulsi Gabbert is the
only serious candidate and I'm supporting
her.
I don't know what that would do in terms of
the audience's relationship to the show.
Uh, and, and I don't yet know who I am supporting,
but I think there is a discussion to be had
about should I, as soon as I decide who I'm
supporting, become a campaigner for that person
on the show in the context of the primary.
Um, or should I just wait until Massachusetts
votes in whenever it is, March of 2020.
I guess it is a, and at that point say who
I'm voting for, I don't know.
My goal is we need to remove Donald Trump
and whatever role I can play in making that
more likely, that's the role I want to play.
So I want to hear from you about this.
Uh, what, what, to what degree should I be
actively cheerleading for a particular candidate
in the Democratic primary?
I've already said who I like best, and it's
the two people I consider to be the most progressive,
uh, Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and
I would gladly vote for either in the eventual
general election.
Let me know what you think and maybe we'll
follow up about this
bonus show, which by the way, you should become
a member right now so you can access the bonus
show, sign up in, under a minute at www dot.
Join Pacman,